[Music]
new in theaters this weekend ant-man and
the wasp and already in theaters as of
July 4th the first purge this is your
weekend ticket that on the play which is
filthy they have bigger problems another
Marvel movie what a surprise
ant-man and the wasp it's theaters this
weekend and this sequel to the first
ant-man and the 20th film in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe ant-man played by
Paul Rudd again teams up with you
guessed it the wasp played by Evangeline
Lilly come on Paul Rudd and Evangeline
Lilly it's basically a clueless lost
universe mashup and then join the
Avengers which is what caused the rift
between ant-man and wasps and is what
caused her to be then pursued by the FBI
which sent her on the lam so she never
really disappeared they broke up and she
was like I'm out dude sorry I've got to
run this movie is for you if you missed
the good old days of the Prix nanos snap
MCU Paul Rudd as an action hero makes
you giggle in and voluntarily clap your
hands or like me you are just now
realizing that an ant-man isn't just an
uncle that's a terrible joke system
announcing the commencement of the first
purge party in theaters as of July 4th
is the first purge this is the fourth
installment and prequel to the purge
series and shows us the origins of the
first annual purge a 12-hour period
where crime is legal if I were in the
purge so much jaywalking boy from the
people that brought you insidious
paranormal activity and get out this
dystopian action horror film is sure to
deliver this movie is for you if you
love the other purge films you're
intrigued by not so distant future
dystopian stories or you like masks that
is your weekend ticket if you were a
Marvel superhero what would your powers
be well I'd have a
made out of brass and be called brass
man check back next week to watch the
rock pull and on foot evel knievel brass
man out
[Music]